All right.
Today we're going to break down
a really fascinating article
that tries to explain America's
recent cultural shifts, and it
does it using one single
powerful metaphor.
It's a story about a ship of
state, a mutiny, and what the
author calls the 80% of the
country that has just woken up.
So the whole idea here hangs on
this really powerful metaphor.
I want you to imagine America
not as a country, but as a
gigantic aircraft carrier.
Now, how this ship moves and how
it's being steered, that's the
key to this entire argument.
For most of American history,
the author says this ship moved
at what he calls tectonic speed.
You know, like continent
shifting.
It was slow, it was grinding,
but it was stable.
And that slow pacement culture
could be absorbed.
People had generations to adjust
their footing on the deck.
But then things changed.
A new cultural elite, you could
say, grabbed the wheel and they
tried to drive this massive
aircraft carrier like it was a
speedboat.
All of a sudden, change wasn't
slow anymore.
It was turbocharged with these
sharp, immediate turns trying to
change the nation's entire
cultural direction on a dime.
And what happens when you do
that?
Well, as the author puts it, you
just can't turn a carrier that
fast without causing absolute
chaos.
It's not integration at that
point.
It's just cultural whiplash for
everybody on board.
And that whiplash, the article
argues, well, it always, always
leads to a backlash.
OK, So what does this cultural
whiplash actually look like in
the real world?
The author points to what some
people call focusing events.
These are little moments that
take a widespread kind of vague
feeling of unease and
crystallize it into a specific,
tangible grievance.
For instance, the article brings
up these absurd, almost you
can't make this up kind of
incidents.
A DOJ lawyer throwing their
lunch at a cop isn't a national
crisis, of course, but it
becomes this really potent
symbol for people who feel like
the very institutions that are
supposed to be about order are
acting totally out of control.
And it's not just these weird
one off incidents.
Policy decisions can become
these focusing events too.
Like when a city decides to get
rid of core math requirements in
the name of equity, it can make
a lot of people feel like the
actual ground is shifting right
under their feet.
Or, you know, think about the
corporate world.
There's this incredibly jarring
feeling when a company is
sending out memos about pronoun
etiquette at the exact same time
it's laying off thousands of
people.
It creates this powerful sense
that the people in charge have
priorities that are completely
disconnected from reality.
So according to the article,
this constant feeling of
whiplash, all of these focusing
events, they didn't just
disappear, they woke something
up.
They awakened what the author
calls the 80%, a sort of silent
majority that had just been
going along with things until
they couldn't anymore.
Now, let's be clear, this 80%
isn't some scientific poll
number.
It's more of a concept, right?
It's meant to represent this
huge chunk of the country,
everyone from farmers to union
members to even old school
liberals who all at once felt
like the ship was turning way
too fast and in a direction they
definitely did not sign up for.
And here's the crucial part.
This is not a formal political
party.
It doesn't have a shared
platform.
The author calls it a coalition
of strange bedfellows.
Think about it.
These groups don't agree on what
they want to build, but they
found this powerful temporary
unity in what they wanted to
stop.
Their bond wasn't ideology, it
was a shared disgust.
And this shared disgust which
was fueled by years and years of
this cultural whiplash, it
boiled over.
It led to what the author
dramatically describes as a full
on mutiny.
The 80% decided it was time to
take back the wheel.
What was this mutiny really?
It was basically a giant
collective.
No, it was the passengers on the
aircraft carrier realizing they
were being driven like a
speedboat, and they grabbed the
wheel to stop the reckless
maneuvering before the whole
thing just capsized.
But here's where it gets really
interesting.
Winning the mutiny creates a
whole new problem.
The new coalition, they have
their hands on the helm now.
They have the levers of
political power.
But the old elite, while they've
been knocked below decks, they
still control the ship's
intercom, the media, academia,
all the cultural institutions,
they shape the entire narrative.
So from down below decks, the
old guard, they can't steer the
ship anymore.
But what they can do is get on
that intercom and just blast out
pure agitprop.
They're not burdened by actually
having to govern anymore.
So they can narrate every single
bump in Jolt as proof that the
new crew is failing.
They can just scream iceberg
over and over again to try and
create a panic.
And all of this sets up the
final really critical question
of this whole piece.
Was this mutiny a permanent
transfer of command, or was it
just a brief fiery moment that's
eventually just going to burn
itself out?
The author lays out this
three-step challenge for the new
crew.
Step one, seize the wheel.
OK, check.
They did that.
But the really hard work is
still ahead.
Step 2 is rewiring that
intercom, winning the narrative.
And the even harder Step 3 is
redrawing the maps by building
new, lasting institutions of
their own.
And this really gets to the core
of the problem.
As the author puts it, revolts
are exhilarating.
Governance is exhausting, the
adrenaline rush from the mutiny
is over, and now comes the slow,
boring, frankly unglamorous work
of actually steering the ship
day in and day out.
And you can really see the
difference in strategy here.
The old elite, their whole game
was about permanence.
They achieved it by slowly,
methodically seeding their
worldview into all the major
institutions on the other side.
The new Coalition's challenge is
just endurance.
Can they turn that initial
frustration into durable rules
and resist the burnout and
infighting before the job is
done?
And so we're left with this big
unresolved question.
Has this 80% actually managed to
set the American ship of state
on a permanent new course?
Or was there awakening just a
brief bright flare in the dark
before the old crew just comes
back up and retakes the helm?